there was a great great animated film
from the 80s called called The Last
Unicorn
do you know this movie yes I remember
that it's weirdly kind of scary I feel
like LSD culture was still heavily like
slipping into kids art in in our
childhood like because like fraggle
rocks and stuff yeah or like um remember
that first The Hobbit cartoon trippy
trippy it was like trippy yeah there was
a lot of that trippy ass [__] you can
tell like the difference of like the
drugs like so like everyone's like
smoking weed you know I think cocaine
starts and we get like Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles
and like oh like their boss is like a
rat and uh we love pizza they love pizza